NO TAX.
JAKE.
>> OF COURSE.
DREW GRIFFIN, THANKS.
>> TURNING TO BREAKING NEWS NOW
IN OUR PALTICS LEAD.
DONALD TRUMP IS SEEKING WHAT IS
KNOWN AS A SPECIAL MASTER, A
THIRD-PARTY ATTORNEY WHO WOULD
REVIEW WHETHER MATERIALS THE FBI
SEIZED FROM MAR-A-LAGO COULD BE
USED IN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
CNN'S KATELYN POLANTZ AND
KAITLAN COLLINS ARE TRACKING THE
LEGAL DEVELOPMENT.
THE FIRST THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS MADE SINCE HIS
PRIVATE RESIDENCE WAS SEARCHED.
KATELYN POLANTZ, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
WHAT IS TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
ASKING FOR?
>> ESSENTIALLY, DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS LEGAL TEAM WANT TO PUMP THE
BRAKES ON ANYTHING THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COLLECTED AND
WOULD BE GOING THROUGH NOW IN
THIS ONGOING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
SO TO DO THAT, THEY'RE ASKING IF
FOUR THINGS.
THEY'RE ASKING FOR A SPECIAL
MASTER, SO A THIRD PARTY THAT
WOULD BE APPOINTED BY THE COURT
TO MAKE SURE WHAT IS COLLECTED
IN THE EVIDENCE IS THE SORT OF
THING INVESTIGATORS CAN USE AS
THEY CONTINUE INVESTIGATING.
HE ALSO WANTS TO PAUSE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FROM
REVIEWING THAT INFORMATION,
THAT'S NUMBER TWO.
NUMBER THREE, HE WANTS A MORE
DETAILED RECEIPT OF THE PROPERTY
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO HIM.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE FBI PROVIDED TWO
RECEIPTS TO HIM, THAT HIS LAWYER
SIGNED AT THE END OF THAT SEARCH
WHEN THEY REMOVED 33 ITEMS.
HE WANTS MORE DETAIL ABOUT THAT.
AND FOUR, HE WANTS THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO RETURN ANY ITEMS
THAT THEY SAY WOULD NOT BE
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THE SEARCH
WARRANT THAT WOULD BE FOUND TO
BE THAT WAY BY THIS SPECIAL
MASTER IF IT WOULD BE APPOINTED.
SO THOSE ARE ALL OF THE THINGS
HE'S ASKING FOR.
HE'S ALSO MAKING SOME LEGAL
CLAIMS SAYING HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS MAY BE VIOLATED, THERE
ARE PROTENTIALLY PRIVILEGED
MATERIALS TAKEN OUT OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
BUT OF COURSE, WE NEED TO PUT
SOME CAVEATS IN THIS, IN THAT
THERE WAS A HEARING LAST WEEK.
THERE WERE LOTS OF CHANCES FOR
DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM TO SPEAK UP
IN COURT.
THEY DID NOT DO THAT.
IT HAS BEEN TWO WEEKS SINCE THIS
SEARCH, SINCE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD ALL OF THIS
EVIDENCE IN THEIR POSSESSION,
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE FBI
DID RECEIVE MANY THINGS, GO
THROUGH THEM, AND THEIR FILTER
TEAM WAS AT WORK AND EVEN
RETURNED TO TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
THINGS THEY DIDN'T NEED IN THAT
INVESTIGATION, INCLUDING TWO
EXPIRED PASSPORTS AND A
DIPLOMATIC PASSPORT FOR THE
FOREIGNER PRESIDENT.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT THE JUDGE DOES
HERE.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A RESPONSE YET
IN COURT TO THIS.
>> KAITLAN COLLINS, WHAT ELSE
ARE YOU DISCOVERING IN THIS
DOCUMENT?
>> A LOT, JAKE.
IT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY DETAILED
ABOUT THEIR VIEW OF HOW ALL OF
THIS TRANSPIRED LEADING UP TO
THIS SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO.
WE SHOULD NOTE IT ALSO REVEALS
THAT THE SEARCH WARRANT WAS
ACTUALLY SIGNED ON AUGUST 5th,
THAT FRIDAY BEFORE IT WAS
ACTUALLY CARRIED OUT AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY'RE RAISING THE QUESTION IN
THIS FILING ABOUT WHY THE SEARCH
WARRANT WAS SIGNED AT 12:12 PL
ON THAT FRIDAY, AUGUST 5th, AND
THE SEARCH WASN'T CARRIED OUT
UNTIL MONDAY.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD A RESPONSE
FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON
THIS MATTER, BUT THEY DO NOTE
THAT THEY SAY THAT JAY BRATT,
WHO WAS THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WHO VISITED MAR-A-LAGO
AT THE PREVIOUSLY REPORTED JUNE
3rd MEETING, WAS THE ONE WHO
ARRIVED.
HE CALLED TRUMP'S COUNSEL AND
THEN ASKED TRUMP'S COUNSEL TO
TURN THE CAMERAS OFF AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
OF COURSE, THAT'S BEEN A POINT
OF DISPUTE.
THERE IS ONE REALLY FASCINATING
THING IN THIS FILING, JAB.
IT IS CONFIRMATION FROM TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM THEY TRIED TO PASS A
MESSAGE ALONG TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL GARLAND.
ON AUGUST 11th, TRUMP'S COUNSEL
CALLED JAY BRATT, THIS JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHO IS
REALLY LEADING THIS
INVESTIGATION, AND ASKED HIM TO
PASS ALONG THIS MESSAGE FROM
TRUMP TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND.
I'M GOING TO READ IT IN FULL
BECAUSE IT SAYS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
KNOW THAT HE HAS BEEN HEARING
FROM PEOPLE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
ABOUT THE RAID.
THERE WAS ONE WORD TO DESCRIBE
THE MOOD, IT IS ANGRY.
THE HEAT IS BUILDING UP, THE
PRESSURE IS BUILDING UP.
WHATEVER I CAN DO TO TAKE THE
HEAT DOWN, TO BRING THE PRESSURE
DOWN, JUST LET US KNOW.
JAKE, PREVIOUSLY, OFFICIALS HAD
NOT CONFIRMED, PEOPLE AROUND
TRUMP HAD NOT CONFIRMED HE DID
TRY TO GET A MESSAGE TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL GARLAND.
THEY ARE CONFIRMING IT IN THIS
FILING, WHICH IS JUST REMARKABLE
IN AND OF ITSELF REALLY, JAKE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO NOTE
IS IT'S BEEN TWO WEEKS SINCE THE
SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO HAPPENED.
THERE HAD BEEN SOME DISAGREEMENT
IN TRUMP'S ORBIT, I WAS TOLD BY
SOURCES, OVER WHETHER OR NOT TO
SEEK THIS SPECIAL MASTER AND HOW
QUICKLY TO DO IT.
SOME CRITICISM THEY HAD KIND OF
MISSED THE WINDOW, THEY SHOULD
HAVE DONE IT SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
OF COURSE, IT IS NOW TWO WEEKS
SINCE THE SEARCH HAPPENED AND
THEY'RE TAKING THEIR FIRST LEGAL
ACTION HERE.
IT DOES SHOW THAT THERE IS SOME
DISAGREEMENT BEHIND THE SCENES
OVER WHAT IS THE BEST STRATEGY
GOING FORWARD.
CLEARLY, THIS IS NOW A DECISION
THEY'RE MAKING.
THEY HAVE ONE THING IN MIND
HERE, HAVING THIS SEARCH FOR A
SPECIAL MASTER COULD POTENTIALLY
SLOW THINGS DOWN SINCE THEY ARE
ASKING INVESTIGATORS TO PAUSE
THEIR WORK UNTIL A SPECIAL
MASTER, THIS THIRD PARTY
ATTORNEY, WOULD BE APPOINTED.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN SENIOR
LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG AS
WELL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF TRUMP'S
CHANCES IN TERMS OF SUCCEEDING
IN THIS FILING AND GETTING A
SPECIAL MASTER TO BE APPOINTED
TO GO THROUGH ALL OF THE
MATERIAL COLLECTED AT MAR-A-LAGO
BEFORE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TAKES WHATEVER THEY FIND
RELEVANT?
>> WELL, JAKE, ON THE SPECIAL
MASTER REQUEST, I THINK DONALD
TRUMP HAS A FAIR LEGOOD CHANCE
OF PREVAILING.
IT'S A REASONABLE REQUEST.
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
THE IDEA IS LET'S GET AN OUTSIDE
THIRD PARTY, TYPICALLY YOU WOULD
HAVE A RETIRED FEDERAL JUDGE
COME IN AND REVIEW THESE
DOCUMENTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE,
POTENTIALLY EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
IF THERE IS, THE SPECIAL MASTER
WILL HOLD ON TO IT.
THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS.
MOST MEMORABLY WHEN DOJ DID A
SEARCH WARRANT ON MICHAEL COHEN
IN 2018, THERE WAS A SPECIAL
MASTER APPOINTED, A FORMER
FEDERAL JUDGE FROM THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK, BARBARA
JONES.
SHE ONLY PASSED ALONG TO
PROSECUTORS THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE NOT PRIVILEGED.
AS KAITLAN NOTES, THIS WILL TAKE
TIME.
IT PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
MADE, THE REQUEST, A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, SHORTLY AFTER THE
SEARCH WAS MADE.
FOR ALL WE KNOW, DOJ IS ALREADY
GOING THROUGH THAT INFORMATION.
BUT THIS IS NOT AN UNUSUAL
REQUEST, AND IT'S FAIRLY WELL
GROUNDED.
>> YOU HEARD KAITLAN REPORT THAT
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM TRIED TO
CONTACT ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND
WITH THIS MESSAGE ABOUT HOW
ANGRY PEOPLE ARE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, WILDLY INAPPROPRIATE AT
A MINIMUM.
LOOK, YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO,
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TRY TO
INFLUENCE A PROSECUTION IN ANY
WAY.
IF YOU'RE A SUBJECT OR A TARGET
OR ANY PERSON, AND REACHING OUT
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HIMSELF
WITH THE KIND OF MESSAGE,
WHETHER IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE
TRYING TO BRING THE TEMPERATURE
DOWN OR NOT IS REALLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND I THINK
ILL-ADVISED.
>> WANT TO BRING IN CAITLYN FOR
A SECOND.
WE HEAR THIS A LOT FROM TRUMP
ALLIES ALONG THE LINES OF THE
FBI BETTER NOT DO THIS, THERE'S
GOING TO BE, LIKE, BAD THINGS
ARE GOING TO HAPPEN.
SOMETIMES IT'S A VAGUE THREAT.
SOMETIMES IT'S PRETTY DIRECT.
>> INTERESTING IS THE POLITICAL
ARGUMENT THEY'RE MAKING IN THE
FILING WHICH IS THEY SAY TRUMP
WHO HAS NOT YET DECLARED HE'S
RUNNING FOR OFFICE IN 2024 S THE
CLEAR FRONT-RUNNER IN THE
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
AND IN THE 2024 GENERAL ELECTION
SHOULD HE DECIDE TO RUN.
THEY'RE ALSO BRINGING THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS INTO THIS,
JAKE.
BASICALLY TRYING TO MAKE THIS
ARGUMENT THAT WHAT TRUMP HAS
BEEN SAYING SINCE THE DAY THAT
HE CONFIRMED THIS SEARCH, WHICH
IS HIS CLAIM IT'S POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
THEY CITE THE PRESS CONFERENCE
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
BASICALLY THEY'RE SAYING, FOR
EXAMPLE, LET ME READ YOU PART OF
THIS JUST TO SHOW YOU THE
ARGUMENT THAT TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
IS MAKING.
ON AUGUST 8th, 2022, IN A
SHOCKINGLY AGGRESSIVE MOVE AND
WITH NO UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISTRESS IT WOULD CAUSE MOST
AMERICANS, ROUGHLY TWO DOZEN
SPECIAL AGENTS OF THE FBI
DIRECTED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WENT TO TRUMP'S HOME.
THAT IS HOW THEY'RE FRAMING IT,
JAKE.
THAT'S RIGHT OFF THE BAT IN THIS
MOTION THEY'RE FILING.
THEIR FIRST LEGAL MOTION WE'RE
GETTING FROM THE TRUMP TEAM.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SAY THIS IS A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED ATTACK
AGAINST TRUMP AND SAYING IT'S
BECAUSE HE'S THE FRONT-RUNNER.
THAT HAS KIND OF BEEN THEIR
STRATEGY ALL ALONG AND WHAT
THEY'RE USING IN A PUBLIC COURT
OF OPINION, CERTAINLY, AS THEY
HAVE BEEN MAKING MOST OF THEIR
LEGAL ARGUMENTS ON TELEVISION.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THEY'RE
MAKING AN ARGUMENT IN A COURT
FILING AND THEY HAD
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO SO
PREVIOUSLY AND HAVE NOT YET DONE
SO.
>> ELIE, CONGRESSMAN DAN
CRENSHAW WAS ON "STATE OF THE
UNION" YESTERDAY AND HE MADE A
SIMILAR ARGUMENT ABOUT JUST THE
INHERENTLY POLITICAL NATURE OF
THIS SEARCH.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE ARE GOING AFTER AN
EX-PRESIDENT WHO MAY RUN AGAIN,
THIS IS AUTOMATICALLY POLITICAL.
YOU CAN'T -- YOU CANNOT SEPARATE
THE LEGAL ASPECTS OF THIS FROM
THE POLITICAL ASPECTS OF IT, YOU
CAN'T.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO ME THEY HAVE
ACTED RESPONSIBLY AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
>> WHAT DID YOU HEAR WHEN YOU
HEARD THE CONGRESSMAN SAY THAT?
>> WELL, JAKE, I'M NOT SURE DAN
CRENSHAW HAS A BASIS TO SAY THAT
DOJ HAS NOT ACTED RESPONSIBLY
HERE.
HE LIKE ALL OF US HAS NOT SEEN
THE AFFIDAVIT.
I DO THINK HE HAS A GOOD POINT
THAT THIS PROSECUTION OR
INVESTIGATION IS INHERENTLY
POLITICAL, AND PROSECUTORS LIKE
TO AND RIGHTLY STRIVE TO OPERATE
SEPARATE AND APART FROM
POLITICS, BUT PROSECUTORS ALSO
OPERATE IN REALITY.
WE CAN'T OPERATE IN A VACUUM AS
MUCH AS WE STRIVE FOR THAT AT
DOJ, AND I THINK HE'S RIGHT THAT
THE CLOSER WE GET TO THE
MIDTERMS AND THE 2024
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION CYCLE, THE
MORE FRAUGHT, THE MORE
POTENTIALLY DIFFICULT IT GETS TO
CHARGE, TO INVESTIGATE, TO
INDICT, POTENTIALLY TO CONVICT
ANYONE, NEVER MIND SOMEBODY WHO
MAY WELL BE THE FRONT-RUNNER.
>> I WOU